gimme how do you feel about the video
well the video well I like rocker rocker
let me talk that um and I'm subscriber
akka raka raka okay it's Rako racket but
you say raka raka that's how you say is
an iraq iraq ax
it's reco record right I mean he just
says a little different it's kind of
weird you're after this is one of the
perfect fan to come on the channel today
I'm up
am I really I mean you got the looks kid
take that point to say no you can't tell
when I'm being serious you know I love
it
but you just say said again please I
feel like this is the best the best this
is a big invest damn my life right now
that's not exactly what you said you're
kind of hamming it up right now
okay whatever guys I'd like you to meet
Jimmy Jimmy hey what's up Jimmy famously
named after that cameo in Batman V
Superman from Jimmy Olsen like that no
man you're pretty good
okay who's Jimmy you might ask you might
be like who's this guy he's not a hot
girl but it's a hot dude
Jimmy is actually a fan of the channel
how did we meet exactly this little girl
not sound good
I don't start off sentences normally
with how I know little girls she was
like I know your channel and then she
has a sister who is your girlfriend
she's my girlfriend
yes and then your girlfriend met me and
then this is kind of a funny story
it is his girlfriend was so into me and
I was like dude look you got a boyfriend
I've never met the girl ugly some
luggage bag or something person oh she
like no she set the complete opposite
she was like ah this guy oh he's always
smoking he's going to go he's so funny
he's like oh he's like talking [ __ ]
about you that I was totally making each
other's eye real does she really do that
it's me I would you know know you're a
fan of the channel why don't you put me
down what would you do that fan I found
Jimmy is an aspiring actor yeah
and he's into music right now he's got a
SoundCloud account yeah I don't music
there yet but it'll be there then
imagine this guy's voice this face you
get a fan of raka raka transition meet
the McDonald's a lot of people are
suggesting that I we watched this video
I'm a tracker racket before did you know
that you know did you know I did that
that's how awesome I am really bad like
it's freaking me I feel sensitive around
you sensitive yeah oh my gosh
Oh
my sister Oh God okay she she looks nice
the question I ask myself is like how do
they get all these actors into this
really dudes exactly yeah guess friends
Oh
city
Hey
you
formula
okay
oh I guess
oh my god
comfortable Oh God
this is totally around sabe
apparently they're like Rob Rob Davi
faster they have to be
Oh baby
I feel like there's an actual story here
with a rack of record video
y'all just making fun of Ronald McDonald
now we're meeting this family of the
McDonald I know their work they're still
working on a film I hope it's not like
something Ronald McDonald film I don't
think they never get away with that yeah
I like the family I thought the family
was great because this is this I thought
this was sort of a brilliant video
because you got a wide variety of
different family members here and it's
done like Devil's Rejects kind of style
it's really sick handheld and gory I was
like okay things like Hanukkah family I
have extended relatives when I go to
these family parties on my Filipino side
it's a large family so this is kind of
disturbing because this isn't just like
mom brother you know this is like the
entire McDonald family and I love the
plot of that there's a secret formula
the McDonald's formula okay I feel like
this is an actual web series I could get
into you know what you starve into the
Burger King had like body voice a
YouTube ad origin or so yeah exactly
YouTube rhetoric to see me wait to
contribute to the conversation in a
positive way new information something
that did not pop in my noggin I'm proud
of your property my own proud of you
doing good you're doing good keep it up
my fans are also my students are they
know they are now I also soon I was a
student once who's dead maybe like high
school no no I was a student of me you
don't okay when I mess with you it's
totally different when you mess with me
it's just uncomfortable you don't have a
sister do you
I do oh you do I have a younger sister
she's 15 so does that bother you
Jimmy that there's like incest happening
here does it make you think of you
making out
with your own sister well now that you
bring it up yet this how does that make
you feel because you'll come talkable
uncomfortable okay that's a that's a
healthy response it's accepted out here
in California yeah there's other parts
of America you can go to if you're
attracted to your sister I have a sister
too and that makes me uncomfortable
because the thought of my sister and I
mean out literally makes me want to kind
of put it on YouTube as a viral video so
that way are you giving some money
think about it could be okay yeah how is
that goes long but you don't know a
sister like yeah yeah do makes out with
the snow yeah it makes out with his
sister after watching ragged records
meet the McDonald and my grandma in real
life I might one of my grandma's passed
away and my other grandma she's
currently ill um so this is a really
serious topic the way he was treating
his grandma Oh
twisting forever yeah do that to her
while you know she's ill no yeah not
what not while she's ill you know
anything about those kids watching this
with you think about the kids watching
this video yeah I don't want you know
twisted I have I have people get mad if
I say on the Internet I'm like dude this
is this time this is a family of hurting
themselves that's [ __ ] funny maybe
they're trying to tell us that
McDonald's is you know evil by you know
dressing up like Ronald McDonald does
not evil that's what makes it fun is
because it's it it's a joke because
everyone knows
Donn's is far from you fine
Trump oh yeah where you guys hate trunk
right um it depends how do you feel that
wrong you're Mexican did you like him
right
sometimes a bad guy in his head
maybe he's thinking he's a good guy you
know you know what I really thought the
last half of that sentence was gonna be
a lot more badass sometimes the bad guy
in his head and then you just said
thinks he's the good guy he could have
really made that last half about last
line so much good boy
really yeah I'm saying you almost had a
tag line there I'm up doggy I'm saying
keep working on it
yeah then we got a movie Hollywood here
we come we're gonna wreck a wreck this
video is about nothing you guys have to
subscribe to Rocco Rocco right now
seriously this one's got another
brilliant there survive they won't let
you down just won't let you I won't
trust us and me and Jimmy you do music
right yeah okay um I got a little rhythm
here for you I'm gonna go what's your
name Jamie no no no stop Jimmy oh yeah I
want to say um who's Jim who teach in
the USA me me oh that's badass right
there who's Jim me Jim me II da dum dum
am I playing warrior game thanks man
comfortable
I don't really know he's joking around I
follow him on Instagram see what's your
Instagram uh a kid named Jimmy that's
cute
you're a cute guy and I got like calm
your confident ladies got to love you
from what I remember when your
girlfriend was really hitting on me I
thought really I think I thought she was
pretty it was so late
it just happens often in my
when girls are oh it's a weird thing I
think it's the pheromones I give off